some beachgoers in the Northeast may
have to make other plans after high
levels of bacteria were found in the
water at least five northeast states
have been posting at beaches lakes and
ponds because of water quality Elaine
quijano is in Boston she's got the
latest warning from the health officials
at Constitution beach in Boston swimmers
were given this advisory after elevated
levels of bacteria were detected in the
water in Massachusetts there were 71
Beach closures or advisories on Thursday
alone after water tests showed high
levels of fecal matter and colonies of
bacteria that could make swimmers sick I
have you know health issues that would
be I would be vulnerable experts say
recent heavy rainfall along the east
coast overflowed combined sewer systems
in the state pushing human waste into
the rivers and to beaches what's the
danger if people go swimming in this
water people could get sick and many
could have a mild illness something like
nausea or vomiting some people can have
skin reactions you can even get an eye
infection or an ear infection Nationwide
more than 1400 beaches had at least one
swim advisory or closing last year the
head of Massachusetts Public Health
Department says more Beach closures
could be the new normal as we see
increasing rainfall and increasing
severe weather patterns mostly
associated with climate change we're
seeing increases in the number of beach
Waters that need to be closed down
because of contamination I wanted to
make a sandwich out of that Dan Doherty
the head of operations for Kelly's Roast
Beef on Revere Beach says the 10 Beach
closures so far there this summer have
affected their bottom line we're off
about 40 percent from last year with the
closures people aren't coming down here
to wait in line for you know roast beef
sandwich
as for a long-term solution experts say
separating Massachusetts combined sewer
systems so sewage is in one pipe and
storm water in another would be a
permanent fix